TJ is with us in Huntsville Alabama hi
TJ hi Dave I'm calling because my
husband and I are trying to figure out
if we're making the right decision to
refinance a car we only we are at that
three other than our car however net
worked really really hard to get to a
position to buy a house currently we
live in public housing and we have done
all the smart things to get ourselves in
that position except do a stupid thing
by buying a car how much do you owe on
we owe a little over 14 and what's your
household income 29 you just show the
car well the thing is you need to show
look where we live we is your head as
you're living a lovely housing and
you're driving a $14,000 car on that and
you make 29,000 none of these numbers
work I understand that accept the
because of where we live the car has
damaged due to some shooting that went
on out there and so I'm not sure we
could get even what it's worth now yeah
watching what's out on it yeah you may
have to borrow a little bit just to get
out of it but I'd rather you have a
thousand dollars and a debt and get that
pay done before you buy a home then I
would well yeah we put the home we put
the home purchase off until the car is
paid off but what we're thinking is we
could refinance it for a lower rate and
pay it off faster because our credit is
good enough to do that that's good I'm
glad your credits good but your car is
50% of your income isn't your car poor
right you got too much invested in car
right now with your income what kind of
track is your income on do you think
your household incomes going to go up
substantially soon well it's gone up by
about 600 in the past five months
so we're actually building we're growing
but trying to do things smart but good
if we
we did this a year and a half ago when
what I'm asking is about your household
income are your all careers on
is there something getting ready to
happen that's going to cause a leap in
that income or is it just a steady slow
increase at this point of steady flow in
creature then if that's the case then
the car is too expensive for your
household income and I can I would tell
you to sell it and get you
you know I'd save up and get me about a
four or five thousand on a car that I
pay cash for and that's going to get you
out of that faster and get you into a
home faster anyway which is your
ultimate goal but I know you don't want
to sell the car TJ but I'm telling you
the numbers when I'm selling the car I
just don't don't really know the process
about how to do it smartly as far it was
really loan well it's Ricci okay all
right you might talk to them about
letting you sign a note for the
difference what's your interest rate on
this car it is off the chart it's twelve
point nine seven yeah okay is it but so
you first thing is you need to find out
what the cars worth go to Kelly Blue
Book calm and see what you can sell it
for putting it on on the Craigslist or
something right well let me ask you with
the the car is in really good shape with
the exception of the bullet holes in the
bumper should we fix that and then sell
the car in good condition or how many
bullet hole er in the bumper - okay
that's probably not a big deal breaker
okay I don't think that's probably going
to mess it up too bad I mean so I would
yeah I would let's get that thing on the
market and really let's go ahead and get
rid of it rather than trying to repair
that and you can discounting somewhat
for you know get an estimate on the
repair if you want and so somebody asks
about it you know you could say well I
looked at the body shop set it up like
this to fix it you know that kind of
thing and and but let's go ahead and get
that thing turned now let's say they yo
14 and it'll only bring 13 you got to
come up with that other thousand which
means you're probably going to have to
borrow that other thousand but I'd
rather you be a thousand dollars in debt
then fourteen thousand dollars and debt
on a car when you're making
twenty-nine and you're living in public
housing so I'm glad you're on your way
out and proud of you
keep it up keep fighting it through and
if I can help you more TJ you call me
anytime this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]